i feel like i have a bazillion good  ideas which is probably true i'm always  like i don't want to tell anybody  because i don't want anybody to steal my  idea but stupid learned is growing up is  execution it's my hardest part  execution's everything i think the  reason i've popped is because i'm giving  away all my best info for free i do that  because 99 of people don't do anything  about it the punch line is like i'll  tell you what to do i'll tell you how to  make content on facebook and instagram  and snapchat and youtube that can lead  to good things selling more homes  getting a promotion i can tell you what  to do the reality is somewhere in my  late 20s early 30s i'm like wait a  minute people don't do it and you're  right execution